we're living in a very risk-averse
society which is driving me nuts i think
we're killing this nation with how risk
verse were getting because a true
breakthrough requires tremendous levels
of risk my name is peter diamandis and
i'm the chairman and CEO of the XPrize
foundation but run a number of other
companies determine of singularity
University co-founder managing director
of space adventures and zero g and
chairman the rocket racing and i'm a
nine-year-old kid having fun i have
wanted to fly into space since childhood
I was a kid born in the 60s grew up with
Apollo and bought the you know the story
that all of us would have a chance to
fly into space and frankly the pace at
which we had been moving in the 60s
should have given us that capability but
the race against the Soviet Union
basically ended when we land on the moon
and politicians gave up on that vision
of the future and technology really died
off very quickly and I realized that my
chance of becoming an astronaut or one
in a thousand and so that wasn't my
vision my vision of flying into space is
like a scuba diver you know when you
want to go scuba diving or mountain
climbing or whatever your sport is you
can go and do it so I made a commitment
to myself after going through medical
school and getting my engineering
degrees that I was going to do it
privately and the original XPrize the
ansari x prize was an effort to build a
private spaceflight industry that would
allow all of us to go with our own
hard-earned money and explore this
frontier so opening the space frontier
for example with the ansari x prize you
know it's 2003 we've got 26 teams around
the world who are building private space
ships to carry you and I up into space
and the realization is that the rules
and regulations in the united states
don't allow for private spaceflight they
allow for one way you know you know
expendable launch vehicles they don't
allow for vehicles to re-enter and they
don't allow for people to buy tickets
and so i have to go to the f
administrator Marion Blake in state
Marion we've got a problem you know the
ansari x prize for Space Flight we've
got teams about to start competing but
they can't compete in the United States
they're going to have to go to Mexico or
Canada or Russia to go and fly their
vehicles and much to her credit she said
we'll have to change that won't we and
so the rules and regulations to allow
for you know round-trip travel and when
i like to call you know carbon-based
payloads you know you and I to go was
who had to be created so a lot of
breakthroughs run into regulatory
structures that are inflexible and
sometimes it's not about the technology
it's about changing what the regulations
allow and as we open up space that's
going to be more and more the challenge
so how do we allow people to really
innovate take risks one of my companies
for example is a company called zero
gravity corporation we have a couple of
727s and we take people up into
weightless parabolic flight couple years
back we flew Stephen Hawking the world's
expert in gravity in zero g and that was
a really amazing experience to see this
man has been wheelchair bound for 40
years float freely in the zero-g
airplane now NASA's been doing zero-g
flights for the last 40 years since the
late 50s they were flying people in
zero-g airplanes and in 1993 myself and
another colleague Byron lichtenberg who
had flown to shuttle missions and I
walked into the FAA and we said we would
love to take the public the paying
public up 40 G flights and we're going
to put 35 people in the back the
airplane unstrap them from their
seatbelt put the airplane up into a 45
degree climb push it over the top and
they'll float out and they said you want
to do what it isn't going to happen and
literally you know the legal structure
that we had formulated there was no
place in the rules and regulations of
the Federal Aviation Regulations that
would allow this to occur and I remember
the conversations I have with the
lawyers that basically said we're in the
regulations does it allow it to happen
and my answer was wearing the
regulations does it dis allow it to
happen and we've gone from a society
where if it's not explicitly prohibit
it's legal to a society where if it's
not explicitly allowed it's illegal and
that's a very dangerous shift it took us
11 years to get approval from the FAA to
do this it was battling the regulations
all the way over regulation for a new
field means you know dead at arrival the
early days of aviation was one that a
lot of risk was taken and consequently a
lot of lives were lost and people were
willing to risk their lives for that
which they believed in in 1919 a
Frenchman Raymond Ortega been born in
Paris moved to New York became an
entrepreneur start as a busboy
eventually own two hotels he loved
aviation and so I would it could do in
in war and wanted to use it in peacetime
so he offered up a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar prize for
the first person to fly between new york
and paris and that
twenty-five-thousand-dollar or tag prize
was ultimately what motivated Lindbergh
to cross the Atlantic in 1927 and it's
what ultimately motivated me to create
the XPrize I read about about the art a
prize I had no idea that it existed i
read about it in Lindbergh's memoirs and
called spirit of st. Louis and I was
making notes and I realized oh my god
this twenty five thousand dollar prize
caused nine different teams to spend
four hundred thousand dollars to win the
$25,000 and the most unlikely guy to win
it was Lindbergh Lindbergh literally had
been flying the air mail for a number of
years no one would even some an airplane
or an engine because they were scared
that he would crash and give him a bad
reputation but in 1927 mate 20th he
takes off as well field he lands 33 a
half hours later in lib rachet and the
fact that he did it was not the coolest
thing what was the most amazing part of
the or take prize that was that between
1927 and the end of nineteen
twenty-eight 18-month period the number
of passengers the United States went
from 6,000 to 180,000 it was a 30-fold
increase in the amount of passenger
travel because this dramatic
demonstration of this of Lindbergh is
young
aeronaut today's regulatory structure
going back what is it 80 years into the
early you know teens and 20s would have
effectively shut down the
experimentation days of aviation there
is a challenge when you're giving birth
to new industry if it's a new industry
that is dissimilar to anything that
existed before like the dot-com
revolution was and there aren't the
regulatory structures there to plug them
into those industries have a period of
very rapid growth that is unregulated
and revenue begins people start figuring
out how to make it into businesses that
was true of aviation that was true of
the dot-com revolution and then when
serious business comes online then
government comes in and sees where the
faults aren't starts to regulate but
there's a real constituency there the
challenge is when you're giving birth to
a new industry that looks like something
else and you try to apply existing
regulations for an 80 year old aviation
business to a five year old commercial
space business then you've got a
challenge because you don't have the
chance for the real growth and
experimentation to take place the reason
that we have an aviation industry today
is because there wasn't regulation in
the early days aviation had there been
we would never have had the number of
flights to learn so what happens is if
you're allowed to take risk early on you
can learn you can have failures you can
recover from those failures and continue
and learn through the process of doing
to cause the true breakthroughs that we
need to go into space is it's a
requirement to take risk we don't know
what's going to work we're looking for
breakthroughs and in society today we're
living in a very risk-averse society
which is driving me nuts i think we're
killing this nation with how risk-averse
were getting because a true breakthrough
requires tremendous levels of risk you
know the day before something is truly a
breakthrough to crazy idea if it wasn't
a crazy idea the day before then it
wouldn't be a breakthrough being
incremental improvement so computing on
silicon and amusing
vacuum tubes was a crazy idea but we're
in society today do we allow for this
risk to take place large government
programs don't take them because they're
worried about congressional
investigation large corporations are
worried about their stock price
plummeting if they fail so it's really
in the entrepreneurial sector that
people are willing to risk their lives
risked their fortunes their reputations
to do something they fundamentally
believe they can do and when they take
that level of risk then there is the
chance for amazing breakthroughs and
that's where it starts to really become
fun
you